Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome to Sacramento!
Now Sacramento is a really interesting looking game
and I mean that quite literally
I don't usually judge games by just it's looks alone
This one in particular is so fascinating
Because it blends together 2D styling
in this really cartoonish and jittery way
in a 3D world
and I've never played it before and I know this concept is not new
But the way that its presented itself is just so interesting
Because it says that it's a game about exploration and discovery
and again that's not a new concept but
I don't know, something about this game seems intriguing to me
(Mark screams) Hello
Hiii! Are you naked???
Am I bothering you?
Why are you in this purple forest all by yourself?
I'm sorry, I've just... Oh.. Sorry sorry..Excuse me
I'll just move on then :)
(surprised) Hiii!
Hello!
How are you?
Ooo.. Hiii
Ohhh!
Ohhh, you're so pretty!
Ohh Hiii!
Ohh excuse me!
Excuuuuuuuse me! :p
Ohhhh
Hiii birbs!
Ohh hii birbs! Helllooo!
Ohhhww.. That's so pretty!
Ohh Hii, there's more bugs flowing around my head!
Hello.... Hiii!!
Ohhh no lo no!!
No no no no, no no no!
No you don't, you don't wanna go that way!
It's death over there :)
Okay alright.. Oo, excuse me!
Parr.. I'm sorry .. Pardon me!
God!! I can just flatten them into the dirt!
I'm sorry about that
Oh I'm sorry
Oh it's so weird
But this is what I meant
Like it it... It's just...
2D..... like..
Frame animation style
That just leads into this weird combination of worlds that I have never seen before
Ohhhhh
Hiiiii
Ohhh hiii!
Ohhh.... I'm guessing this is where I'm supposed to go..
Okaaay!
Alright!
ohhhww!
Hiii!
Ohhhh that's so cooool!!!!!
Ohh that's so cool
I have to say
Ohhh nooooo!
No don't take it away from me
What
I want to go back in!
Awwww come on!
Ohh what the hell you're gonna just let me go in there and then take it all away with the weird upward flowing water!!!
Or are those leaves?
ohh ohh
What's happening??
Ohh
There's a lot more birds than there were before
Ohh no the sun is setting
I don't like that!
Ohh I don't like that at all! :(
I don't even know where I'm going
And why is this sun setting?
Should... should..
Is there something that I'm supposed to do about that?!!
Or is there something to be solved about it??
Ohh hello
Hiii.. Ohh this is new
Hello?!?!
Where are you leading me?
Where can I?? Ohh...
Ahhh man!
I really gotta say, this is easily one of the most visually striking indie games that I've played
Ohhh kayy! (with a laughter)
Hiiii fish!
How's it going??!!
How are you doing?
You.. ohh hiii fish!
Oh ho ho, hey hey hey HEY! Way wayee woah woah! Woah woah woah, where am I?? I'm not doing that!!
Whaat??!
What??! (Mark's too confused!)
(Again, loudly) WHAATT!!
Well that's it??!!
Oh that can't be it!
Ohh come onnnnnn!
Ohh you can't! That can't be it!!
Ohh
That's so.. Is it just gonna send me exactly back where I was??!!
Or is it gonna take me somewhere new?
And maybe when I get somewhere new, maybe I could
Or is it.. No!
Ohh that's it!
That.. That's actually just it!
But that's so weird!
But what's around you? Is there something else? I didn't exactly go everywhere.. I barely got into that fish area :(
If there's something else hidden here then maybe I can find it
I only got in that room for uh.. Oooohh Hiiii!
Ohhh
Hiiii feeesh!
How you doing?? Ohh hiii!
Goodbye! You carry on, I'm gonna go this way!
Coz I don't know what awaits me down these roads!
That's the weird thing about this game, I don't know if it's a matter of exploration but there's no.. objective
And a lot of these experimental games sometimes are lacking purpose and more about... you know...conveying
A concept
You know, not necessarily giving you an objective but giving you like, an idea.
and I think that's what is this one getting across.
I mean the world is very weird and
I don't know where I'm walking to but I'm walking a long.. Ohhhhhhhhhhhh kaaay he he he he he!!
Ohhhhh!!
Alright I'm not supposed to goooo that wayy
But the sun has not set just yet
I just wandered a little too far off into the wilderness
What is that?
What are you?
Ohh.. hii.. Hello.. What is thisss???!
I don't think that's how windmills work
Ohhh you're flying
(laughter) Thaaaat's soooo weeeeird!!
What are you???!
What are any of you?
You are tiny!!!
Helllooo!
(Kissing)
Ohh I kissed it out of existence! :p
I kill everything I kiss! xD
Hiii sun!
How are you doing over here?
Ohhh... Ohhh... Okay... Ohh....
It seem to be venturing off into the bright brightness
But the sun doesn't set
I imagine that the sun doesn't set until you go in that building
And this might send me reeeeeling back to the beginning
But I don't know :(
Where else to go.. Besides this way
Or if there are secrets in the miiiiisty mist!
Uh oh.. Sun is setting.. Uhh uh ho.. Whooosh
Uh oh.. no... I'm not ready
Please... I don't wanna go yet!
Girl... Lady over here
What's the secret of this place?!
What does it mean? Why are there birds?!
What are you reading?! Why are you naked?!
I have so many questions!
I have so many questions
And I guess I don't have enough time to answer them
It's a very fleeting experience
That is, that is absolutely 100%
Like this game is just very very fleeting
You only get a few minutes to be able to explore this world and yet there is a lot of different directions that you could go!
Ohhh
But not a lot of time to get there
And even this is close to me
Ohhh. come on... Nooo.. I fight against you
I rebel against the darkness!
I didn't rebel very hard (LOL :p)
Cuz we're back here now but okay
Don't consume me
NOOOOOOO!!!! Uhh ohh!
Being scooch from behind as well
But that is Sacramento
That is really cool!
I gotta admit, that's a really cool short experience!
I like that! I love that actually!
It felt right... Like you know when you go into a world and it just feels weird but it feels natural for what it is
Despite its weirdness it existed in its own way
In the only way it could
And I know that's philosophical bullshit and whatever that means is up to interpretation but,
I get it
I get it... And now it's really cool
So thank you everybody so much for watching
If you wanna tell me what you think about this game
Or you wanna try it for yourself and maybe there's a secret in there to discover
Or maybe there's no secet to discover
And it is what it is!
Either way let me know in the comments below
Thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always... I will see you...
In the next video
Bubbbyyyee!!